Wladimir Putin ist der blutrünstigste
Herrscher Russlands seit Josef Stalin
meint unser heutiger Gast Russland
Kenner und außenpolitischer
Korrespondent derzeit Michael Schumann
herzlich Willkommen zu Phönix persönlich
vielen Dank schön bei ihnen zu sein Herr
Thomas sie leiten bereits zum dritten
Mal das Moskauer Büro der Zeit sie haben
also seit Jahrzehnten kann man fast
sagen Gelegenheit Wladimir Putin aus
nächster Nähe zu beobachten nun legen
Sie ein Buch vor mit dem Titel Revanche
wie Putin das bedrohlichste Regime der
Welt geschaffen hat warum Revanche was
glauben Sie wofür will Putin sich rächen
ich glaube dass wir in Deutschland Putin
lange Zeit und vielfach unterschätzt
haben ich glaube wir haben in ihm einen
gesehen der Deutsch spricht und in
irgendeiner Form mit uns Geschäfte und
Kooperation sucht tatsächlich ist es so
dass ich Putin im Laufe seiner langen
Amtszeit sehr sehr stark verändert hat
und wir haben in Deutschland dieses
Revanche Moment übersehen dass er
tatsächlich für Beleidigungen die er so
empfand die gar nicht immer als
Beleidigung gemeint waren und schon gar
nicht gegen Russland er hat es aber so
aufgefasst und er nimmt dafür Revanche
und ich glaube auch für Dinge die er
selber als Erniedrigung empfunden hat
für sein Land zum Beispiel den
Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion
auch und das ist ganz wichtig zu sehen
es ist eine Revanche auch im Inneren des
Landes
gegen Menschen die gegen ihn
aufgestanden sind gegen Menschen die zum
Beispiel 2012 dagegen waren das eher ins
Präsidentenamt zurückkehrt zum dritten
Mal
da gegen hat er in den vergangenen zehn
Jahren Revanche genommen und diese
Revanche hat sich das war eine Revanche
ins Innere gerichtet die sich jetzt nach
außen gerichtet hat vor anderthalb
Jahren und schildern sie ja auch in
ihrem Buch also zum Beispiel aus dem
Jahr 2001 wir erinnern uns da hat er im
Deutschen Bundestag gesprochen der Kalte
Krieg ist vorbei natürlich haben wir da
applaudiert sie zitieren auch George W
bush der auch 2001 also gerade in der
Zeit von ein eleven gesagt hat ich
schaute dem Mann in die Augen und in
seine Seele ich fand ihn aufrichtig und
vertrauenswürdig war unsere Sehnsucht
nach Frieden nach weltvereinigung da
einfach zu groß war wieder zu blauäugig
ich glaube wir haben uns ein bisschen
einwickeln lassen von der Persönlichkeit
des Mannes die natürlich eine ganz
andere Persönlichkeit war als dieses
klassische Stereotyp der früher
sowjetischen Führer die ja immer schon
sehr alt und häufig auch ein bisschen
dem Alkohol zu neigend auch Boris Jelzin
der erste russische Präsident ab 1990
fiel die auch so ein bisschen die
Kategorie und dann war da plötzlich so
ein jüngerer der halt eben damals
sagte ich will mit euch zusammenarbeiten
lass uns gemeinsam gegen den Terror
kämpfen und lassen uns dies und das
machen und da haben wir glaube ich schon
damals übersehen was eigentlich im
Inneren des Landes passiert weil die
Repression begann ja ganz vorsichtig
aber schon ein staatsumbau den er in
Sachen der öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien
der staatlichen damals in Russland aber
eben auch im Bereich des der
Zentralisierung des Landes und der
Entmachtung der
föderalsobjekte der Bundesländer
gewissermaßen all das begann damals
schon und daran haben wir geflissentlich
vorbeigesehen und gehofft dass es
irgendwie mit ihm schon gut gehen würde
und zu sehr auf das was er sagte und
weniger auf das was er tatsächlich
machte geschaut aber glauben Sie
wirklich dass er das damals alles von
dem Kopf hatte glauben sie hatte damals
schon eine Linie hat er sich verstellt
hat er uns bewusst in die Irre geführt
hat er sich das damals selber noch
geglaubt wie würden sie das Einschätzen
nein ich glaube nicht dass er damals das
schon alles so plante wie ich überhaupt
glaube dass
Regierungschefs
ob demokratische oder Diktatoren die
treten nicht mit einem Programm an die
Macht und das wird dann in den nächsten
20 Jahren abgeholt so funktioniert der
Politik auch nicht weil es passiert
alles mögliche in der Welt ist passiert
alles mögliche im eigenen Land und
darauf reagieren diese Leute und bei
Putin glaube ich gibt es einen
Kippmoment
Demokrat war er natürlich nie gewesen
aber er war jemand der halt eben für
dieses Hybride System perfekt war jemand
der sich der gelegentlich autoritär
handelte der die Polizei losschickte die
auch schon den zweiten Krieg das war ja
sein Werk damals
1999/2000 grossen ihr rasiert viele
Dörfer zerstört
aber der auf der anderen Seite eben auch
einfach Dinge laufen ließ und gewisse
Freiräume in der Gesellschaft
ermöglichte und einfach weiterlaufen
liest von seinem Vorgänger Boris jetzt
hinterher wesentlich demokratischer
veranlagt war der Kipppunkt war wie ich
glaube 2011 da wollte er wir erinnern
und er hatte damals zwei Amtszeiten
hinter sich und dann hatte er mit die
mitgetauscht dem damaligen
Ministerpräsidenten der wurde Präsident
für vier Jahre und dann war so war der
Deal dann sollte Putin wieder antreten
und er wollte wieder antreten und siehe
da die Menschen liefen in die Straßen
protestierten gegen ihn es hat Proteste
gegenüber dem Kreml gegeben sechs Monate
lang die haben da teilweise campiert und
putin war damals tief schockiert
sein Rating ging in den Keller seine
Popularität und er hatte einen
Schreckbild vor sich und das waren die
arabischen Aufstände die ja ein Jahr
zuvor sich entwickelt hatten und auch
damals eben noch im vollen Gange und er
glaubte jetzt geht mir das so wie
Mubarak in Ägypten oder Ben Ali in
Tunesien und das war der Moment wo er
sagte für meine eigene Machtsicherung
für mein eigenes politisches Überleben
muss ich mir eine neue Erzählung zulegen
und ich muss auch anders vorgehen im
anderen Landes und damals verstärkte
sich halt die Repressionen es wurden die
Agenten Gesetze verabschiedet die dann
alle möglichen Oppositionellen Russen
als Agenten des Auslands verunglimpften
und dann eben auch Straf-
und das halte ich auch für ganz wichtig
er hat sich damals im Nationalismus
verschrieben und das betrifft heute dann
eben auch uns und die Ukraine das ist
eine Entwicklung die ist eben etwas elf
Jahre alt bei ihm wo er der keine
bestimmte Ideologie hatte außer der dass
der stark Stahl dass der Staat stark
sein muss und dass der Herrscher im
Sattel bleiben muss keine andere hatte
und dieser nationalismus ist seither
gewissermaßen seine Leitlinie die ja
auch durch alle seine Aufsätze und durch
alle seine Reden durchscheinen lässt die
gewissermaßen die Leitlinie die ihn dann
auch damals ab 2012 ein gutes Jahr
später schon in einen Konflikt mit der
EU brachte ihm um die Ukraine und die
Zollunion die die Ukraine damals von der
EU angeboten bekam
nun beschäftigen wir uns ja gedanklich
viel mit diesem Machtmittel Angst auch
wenn wir auf Russland schauen und den
Dingen die die Korrespondenten so ja
auch sie jeden Tag da berichten sie
berichten aber zum Beispiel auch in
ihrem Buch dass er und wir haben da eben
schon ganz kurzes gestreift zu tief
gekränkt beleidigt ist weil er auf der
Weltbühne nicht mehr diese Rolle spielt
vermeintlich wie ihr das glaubt dass er
deshalb auch zu diesem
Angriffskrieg und ähnlichen
schrecklichen Dingen die wir ja nun auch
jeden Tag in den Nachrichten sehen
greift sie schreiben aber z.B auch und
das hat mich wirklich gewundert
er sei zutiefst beleidigt gewesen als
der König Charles zum Tod der Queen
kontrolliert hat dass man ihm nicht zu
Begräbnis eingeladen habe ist das
wirklich so schlecht
das war ein Moment wo er mir tatsächlich
sich hingesetzt hat er hat dann ganz
persönlich hatte er hatte ja Elisabeth
II eben auch getroffen und
das war ja ein Moment wo tatsächlich die
größte Zahl an ausländischen
staatsfrauen Staatsmännern sich
versammelte in London also im Grunde
genommen so ein ganz großes
Familientreffen des Globus und da war er
eben nicht dabei und solche Dinge die
tun ihm weh weil er natürlich sich als
jemand sieht der eigentlich gar nicht
isoliert ist sondern der mit der ganzen
Welt außer mit diesem blöden Westen gute
Beziehung unterhält und er stellt dann
halt eben aber an allen Ecken und Enden
immer wieder fest so z.B auch beim G20
Gipfel in Bali das ist dann doch
schwierig ist mit seiner Verankerung in
der ganzen Welt und das eben auch andere
Länder außerhalb
Spaß und Nordamerikas mit ihm ein
Problem haben und ich glaube diese
Beleidigung aber die rührt noch aus
etwas Tieferem
das sind zwei Dinge eigentlich es gibt
ohnehin die Beleidigung oder das Gefühl
des gekränkt Seins Abida auf Russisch
ist etwas was in Russland durchaus weit
verbreitet ist dass man sich nicht
genügend respektiert fühlt es gibt in
Russland Werbebilder für SUVs zum
Beispiel das steht dann drunter damit
man sie respektiert
fährt man so ein Auto
das sind alles
kompensationsreaktionen wie ich glaube
um halt eben ein Gefühl einer gewissen
Zurücksetzung eines nicht achtens
ausgleicht so das ist gar nicht auf alle
Russen so wie ich ich kenne viele Russen
die sind völlig frei von solchen
Gefühlen es gibt aber eben auch solche
Russen und Putin gehört ganz gewiss dazu
der sich solche Dinge das nicht richtig
geachtet werden es gerne zu Herzen nimmt
als Barack Obama der US-Präsident 2014
war es glaube ich sagte Russland sei
eine Regionalmacht das war so ein Moment
was erlaubt sich dieser Obama wir
nuklear macht permanenter
sicherheitsratssitz bei den Vereinten
Nationen warum sagte er sowas und das
sind Momente da hat sich bei ihm glaube
ich etwas akkumuliert und das sind Dinge
die der besten teilweise überhaupt nicht
verschuldet hat oder es sind eben Dinge
die waren unausweichlich
Charles der dritte die
britische Krone die britische Regierung
hatte glaube ich gar keine Wahl den man
konnte man nicht einladen zum
Staatsbegräbnis von Elisabeth II
nur bei Putin führt das dann zu einer
Reaktion die er ich glaube 2018 einmal
exemplarisch vorgelegt hat er sagte er
das war die die alljährliche Rede zur
Lage der Nation und der sagte er der
Westen hat uns jahrelang nicht zugehört
sie haben uns nicht geachtet nicht
zugehört und jetzt sollen sie mal
zuhören und dann dieser so einen Film
abspielen über die neuesten
Nuklearraketen die dann dem Radar
entweichen und die
Schlangenlinien fahren und natürlich
viel schneller sind als alle bisherigen
die dann Washington erreichen könnten in
kürzester Zeit
das ist so ein bisschen diese diese
Reaktion die er selber auch gerne
inszeniert ist nicht nur etwas was ihn
umtreibt sondern er inszeniert das eben
auch gern und seine Anhänger in Russland
nehmen das gerne auf sie selbst haben
ihr erstes Interview mit ihm geführt
da werden sie ja sicherlich oft dran
zurückdenken in diesen Tagen
wie haben Sie sich damals gefühlt
hat er sie war das angsteinflößend für
Sie wir haben sie in erlebt und dann die
nächste Frage natürlich wir erleben Sie
ihn heute
putin war damals bei äußerlich ganz
anderer Mensch also er ging noch nicht
so
breitbeinig und inszeniert wie er heute
gegen er war damals vor 22 Jahren auch
ein bisschen faltiger als heute also man
hat ja ein bisschen an ihm gearbeitet
und
hat nicht mehr die Ränder von damals
unter den Augen die er damals als hart
arbeitender gerade beginnender
Ministerpräsident und Präsident hatte
hatte damals ja auch den titanienkrieg
sofort ausgelöst also viel zu tun er sah
ein bisschen gestresst aus damals aber
er war insgesamt sehr freundlich und
ließ uns die wir davon der Zeit gekommen
waren für dieses Interview auch nicht
besonders lange warten es war unter zehn
Minuten heute wartet oder in den letzten
Jahren wartete man ja teilweise Stunden
auch Staatsmänner die ihm besuchten
ganz wichtig in diesem Gespräch war das
eher so eine Botschaft von ich will mit
dem Westen zusammenarbeiten aussandte
ich möchte irgendwie Teil dieses
erweiterten Westens sein ich möchte
gerne mit euch gegen den Terrorismus
zusammenarbeiten und das war einfach ein
ganz ganz anderer Ton und er war eben
auch einfach vom ganzen Habitus eher
jemand der signalisierte ich sehe euch
irgendwie als Partner ich würde gerne
irgendwie dabei sein und das hat sich
dann wie ich glaube gerade in den Jahren
nach
2011 12 als er wieder ins Präsidentenamt
kam dann sehr sehr stark verändert haben
sie ihm denn 1999 getraut und falls ja
hat sie das sehr umgetrieben in den
letzten Jahren
also getraut habe ich ihm insoweit nicht
als ich wusste ja woher er kam ich
lebte damals in Russland und jemand der
sozusagen vorher der Chef des
Geheimdienst gewesen ist ist per se
nicht jemand traut
außerdem brach er gleich den
tischinienkrieg vom Zaune und das unter
einem Vorwand man hat ja damals in
einigen russischen Städten gab es
Angriffe auf Wohnhäuser die sehr ominös
waren die russische Regierung schrieb
sie sofort tschetschenischen Terroristen
zu da merkte man aber in zwei Fällen
möglicherweise könnte auch der
Geheimdienst dahinter stecken das war
nicht aufgeklärt so dass ich also wie
auch viele denken damals und gehörige
Portion Misstrauen hatte was ich aber
nie gedacht hätte ist dass ich aus
diesem Jahr eher
kleinen schmalen Mann irgendwann dieser
Typ entwickeln würde der einfach mit
täglichen oder wöchentlichen Drohungen
ich könnte auch die Nuklearbombe
einsetzen die ganze Welt in Angst und
Schrecken versetzt das hätte ich damals
nie gedacht und wenn wir relativ wenig
Bilder von ihm wenn dann sind es reden
Aufmärsche oder Märsche die er begleitet
wer kommt denn überhaupt noch ran an ihn
das heißt er sei hermetisch abgeriegelt
in seiner Welt was wissen wir über sein
Privatleben wie lebt dieser Mensch
soweit ich es von außen
wohnen beurteilen kann
ist eher jemand der sich die einen
kleinen Kreis von Leuten hat die ihn
sehen die dann natürlich vielfältig auf
mögliche Viren überprüft werden das ist
glaube ich etwas was ihn sehr umtreibt
dass er nicht nur kovi sondern auch wie
alle alle Formen von
Krankheiten die die werden da
ausreichend getestet das habe ich immer
wieder gehört und teilweise sieht man es
ist eben auch und Berichten Besucher
anschließen der Kreis mit ihm er sich
bespricht sind heute im Wesentlichen
Leute aus den Sicherheitsapparaten man
hatte früher immer das Bild von Putin
der gewissermaßen sich auf zwei Säulen
verlässt das eine sind sozusagen die
Petersburger Liberalen die
Wirtschaftsexperten und das andere sind
die Sicherheitsleute und Geheimdienst
Leute und
muss man sagen also diese Liberalen
haben vollkommen an Stimme und Wort
verloren die dürfen heute allerhöchstens
noch den Rubel stabilisieren und die
wirtschaftlichen Voraussetzungen des
Krieges stabilisieren oder schaffen aber
tatsächlich das was er macht was er
unternimmt das bespricht er mit diesen
Sicherheitsleuten sie sagen die Äußerung
von Olaf Scholz es ist Putins Krieg es
sind nicht die Russen sei falsch warum
ich glaube dass
Putin diesen Krieg
vom Zaun gebrochen hat er hat ihn
geplant er hat ihn gewollt er hat ihn
historisch begründet
und er hat die Befehle dafür gegeben und
zwar in einer Weise die seine Entourage
teilweise selbst überrascht hat
das war ja auch ein Grund warum sie so
schlecht vorbereitet waren
er hat aber und daher half natürlich die
Propaganda einen Großteil der Russen
mitgenommen in diesen Krieg und er hat
es geschafft das tatsächlich ein eine
Mehrheit in diesem Lande glaubt man
diesen Umfragen auf die man sich
natürlich nicht hundertprozentig
verlassen kann aber es gibt auch so ein
bisschen anekdotische Evidenz ich selber
in den Gesprächen die ich hier und da
und führe
treffe einfach wesentlich eher Leute die
diesen Krieg unterstützen und
befürworten als Leute die dagegen sind
und insoweit gibt es dann doch eine
ganze Menge Russen oder eine erschrecken
große Zahl an großen die Putin mit
seinem Krieg unterstützen und die dann
eben auch trotz der Nachrichten die auch
für Russen erreichbar wären wenn sie
denn zum Beispiel auf ihrem Handy sich
so einen Proxy Server laden mit die man
dann halt eben die staatlichen
Restriktionen im Internet umgehen kann
und dann könnte man ich mal ausländische
Fernsehsender auf die hier auf Russisch
auch
senden bzw schreiben wahrnehmen oder
auch die russischen exilen Medien und
könnte sich schlau machen aber viele
wollen es gar nicht viele wollen einfach
nur die Staatsmedien sehen und das
glauben was in den Staatsmedien gesagt
wird weil dass sie selbst eben auch in
einen wie soll ich sagen in eine
homogenere und
entspanntere in einen entspannteres
Verhältnis jetzt mit ihrer eigenen
Umgebung denn es ist tatsächlich heute
sehr sehr schwer gegen diesen Krieg
zusammen wir sind ja jetzt rund wir
nähern uns im Jahrestag dieses Angriffs
sie sagen aber auch die meisten Russen
haben wirklich erst im September
verstanden dass es ein Krieg ist als
diese erste
bislang die erste
teilmobilisierungswelle erfolgt ist die
die Söhne die Väter die Jungen in den
Krieg befehligt wurden es wird in diesen
Tagen immer wieder darum gesprochen dass
es eine zweite mobilisierungswelle geben
könnte viele Rechner mit einer
Großoffensive in den nächsten Wochen
dafür würde man wahrscheinlich noch mehr
Soldaten brauchen glauben Sie dass das
Volk das weiter widmacht also wie weit
es gibt immer wieder Hoffnung dass man
sagt nein irgendwann steht das Volk auf
das lassen sie sich nicht gefallen wie
ist der ihre Einschätzung
ich bin da pessimistisch insoweit als
ich glaube das Volk steht nicht auf ich
glaube tatsächlich dass ich viele darin
einrichten und versuchen im Grunde
genommen jetzt auch den den kopflichen
irgendeiner Weise herauszustrecken
man hat gesehen wie es Leuten ergeht die
öffentlich gegen den Krieg protestieren
die die etwas sagen die sind im
Wiederholungsfall tatsächlich im
Gefängnis gelandet mittlerweile werden
Leute abtransportiert die einfach nur
einen weißen Zettel hochhalten und es
hat in jüngster Zeit das ist eine
Protestaktion gegeben die sehr
interessant ist da wurden Blumen an den
Denkmälern ukraineischer Dichterinnen
und Dichter in Moskau und in anderen
Städten abgelegt zum Zeichen dass man
solidarisch mit der Ukraine ist und mit
den Opfern die zum Beispiel in der
ukrainischen groß knipro böse getroffen
wurden als ein Raketeneinschlag ein
großes Wohnhaus traf das sehen aber
natürlich alle andere wie schwer es ist
zu
demonstrieren und sich dagegen
auszusprechen und deshalb ist es eben
einfacher im Alltag einfach abzutauchen
und in der großen Masse mitzuschwimmen
und ich glaube die
das werden die Menschen beibehalten und
Putin wird es gelingen auch Kraft seiner
Staatsmedien die Leute einfach weiter da
bei der Stange zu halten er könnte aber
auch mal umgekehrt gedacht wenn er
morgen sagen würde
wir kommen hier schlecht voran
eigentlich wird mir das doch langsam zu
teuer mir gehen die Mittel aus ich
drücke die Stopptaste und sage so bis
hierhin und ich weiter wir ziehen uns
auf bestimmte Positionen zurück und
bietet ein bietet mal ehrlich einen
Waffenstillstand an bisher hat er immer
nur unehrliche angeboten und meint das
gar nicht
er könnte in dem Moment glaube ich auch
die meisten Russen mitnehmen er könnte
in diesem Fall wenn er erklären würde
bis hierhin und nicht weiter würden die
meisten sagen ein Glück
wir hatten immer gehofft dass es schnell
vorübergehe und es wäre glaube ich nur
eine Minderheit von extremen
Nationalisten und
Enthusiasten des Krieges die dann sagen
würden also das geht jetzt aber nicht
wir hatten so viele Opfer die meisten
würden auch da mit ihm wieder gehen dann
haben wir hier in Westen eine sehr
heftige Debatte im Moment die
Kampfpanzer sind jetzt freigegeben um
kam Flugzeuge ob man das weiter
intensivieren sollte die militärische
Unterstützung der Ukraine viele Menschen
haben in Deutschland aber auch Angst
dass es dann zu einem doch immer wieder
unterschwellig angetrunken Atomschlag
kommen könnte trauen Sie ihm das zu
ich glaube das Putin jemand ist der
am Ende
ruchlos genug wäre die Atombombe
einzusetzen
ich glaube nur
derzeit nicht der Moment da ist und dass
er derzeit tatsächlich damit einfach
droht
weil er genau weiß dass das bestimmte
Wirkung hat insbesondere natürlich auf
Deutschland aber auch auf andere
Europäer weil wir hier in unmittelbarer
Nähe des Konflikt Geschehens sind und
insoweit setzt er es bisher einfach als
politische Waffe ein
sollte es zu einer Situation kommen in
dir er sich nicht in der Ukraine sondern
wirklich in Russland und seine Macht
seine persönliche Macht selbst
bedroht fühlt
möchte ich nicht ausschließen dass er
dazu greift zu diesem Mittel
als taktische Atomwaffe das heißt also
im Gefechtsfeld im begrenzteren Rahmen
wie auch immer es hat er ja viele
Szenarien gegeben aber ich glaube dass
er jemand wäre der es machen könnte
erschweren kommt hinzu er hat ja nun
diesen
legendären ominösen atomkoffer und der
müsste noch von einer anderen Person
bedient werden
in der Sowjetunion gab es ja ein
Kollektiv letztendlich wir hatten einen
Generalsekretär einen ersten unter
gleichen aber man hat sich halt eben in
der Sowjetunion im Allerkleinsten Kreis
abgestimmt und diese Genossen waren eben
auch da gab es keine so große Diskrepanz
zwischen ihnen unter Stalin war das was
anderes aber unter Stalins Nachfolgern
halt eben tatsächlich mehr dieses
entscheiden im Kollektiv so haben Sie
sich damals für den Afghanistan Krieg
entschieden im Kollektiv das gibt es
heute nicht mehr und das ist weshalb ich
glaube diese Entscheidung die dann so
sehr allein bei Putin liegt und diesen
dann von ihm von komplett abhängigen
Generalstabschef der dann auch noch mal
drücken müsste
und das gibt mir für diesen Moment keine
Sicherheit oder Überzeugung des eher die
Waffe nicht einsetzen würde
genauso wie wir die Debatte führen um
die militärische Ausrüstung der Ukraine
führen wir natürlich in diesen Tagen
auch immer wieder mal lauter mal leiser
die Diskussion darum ob es überhaupt
jemals einen Frieden geben kann in
dieser Situation ob es den überhaupt mit
Putin geben kann viele sagen das ist nur
noch ohne Putin vorstellbar wenn Sie auf
dieses Land schauen das ist und so lange
kennen was können Sie sich vorstellen
was käme nach Putin
zunächst mal keine Demokratie glaube ich
also russland hat ja im 20 Jahrhundert
103 demokratische Anläufe gemacht leider
immer unter furchtbaren Bedingungen
man hatten sie einen Krieg verloren oder
waren dabei ein Krieg gerade zu
verlieren oder sie waren halt eben wie
in den 90er Jahren nach dem Kalten Krieg
in dem sie halt eben auch nicht als
Sieger hervorgegangen sind
ich glaube das Russland durchaus fähig
ist für demokratische Ansätze oder eine
demokratische Entwicklung das haben sie
gezeigt aber ich glaube auch dass es
eben Eliten gab die das immer wieder
systematisch verhindert haben was ich
denke was nach ihm kommen könnte wäre
zunächst mal ein Machtkampf ein wirklich
großer Machtkampf weil es gibt ja keinen
natürlichen Nachfolger der jetzt schon
aufs Gleis gesetzt wäre und nach diesen
Machtkampf dann ein autokratischer
Herrscher der
vielleicht im Sinne Putins vielleicht
aber auch mit ihm bricht und sagt das
müssen wir jetzt mal ganz anders machen
aber halt eben autoritär weiter regieren
würde immer wieder mit der Berufung
darauf weil sonst hier das Land
auseinander viele wofür ich übrigens
überhaupt keine Anzeichen sehe das ist
eine reine russische propaganda-formel
russland hat schon in den 90er Jahren
nach dem Zerfall der Sowjetunion
Russland selbst hat ziemlich gut
zusammengehalten und war ich lebte
damals in Russland meine Ansicht nach
auch nicht vom Zerfall bedroht aber
diese zerfallsformel wird immer wieder
bemüht um autoritäre Herrschaft zu
begründen was ich glaube ist wenn Putin
ginge
könnte dieser Krieg sehr sehr schnell
beendet werden weil jeder andere
Herrscher autoritär oder weniger
Autorität könnte sagen das war sein
Krieg und wir versuchen uns jetzt mal
ganz anders nun leben sie ja schon
relativ lange in Moskau oder immer
wieder in Moskau wir haben gerade
darüber gesprochen sie sind zum dritten
Mal Leiter des Moskau Büros sie
schreiben Frank und freigelegen dieses
Buch vor indem sie auch sehr weit gehen
in der Einschätzung die bedroht fühlen
sie sich da denken sie da nicht auch
manchmal was kann ich jetzt noch
schreiben was kann ich nicht schreiben
wie geht's ihnen da persönlich
also es ist immer sehr schwer
einzuschätzen inwieweit natürlich die
Macht darauf reagiert was man so sagt
und tut und lässt ich habe eine relativ
lange Erfahrung aus den 90er Jahren und
hat halt über Russland ich habe
eigentlich immer gerade ausgeschrieben
und gesagt was ich denke und meine
und
ich habe damit schon Erfahrungen in der
frühen putinzeit gemacht mal als man
eine als sozusagen Putin freundliche
Publizisten im staatlichen Dienste
damals halt so eine Kampagne gegen mich
damals entfachten und mir unterstellten
ich würde irgendwie von russischen
Oligarchen die gegen Putin sein bezahlt
und es hat immer wieder Versuche gegeben
natürlich durch bürokratische
Einschränkung
das Korrespondenten da sein zu behindern
die Korrespondenten Büros zu behindern
das ist übrigens etwas was nicht nur auf
mich sondern dass das trifft auf alle in
Moskau derzeit auch lebenden
Korrespondenten zu alle haben irgendwie
mit bürokratischen Problemen zu tun die
die bewusst beigeführt werden es gibt
bei der Einreise gab es im vergangenen
Jahr vielerlei Befragungen am Flughafen
das sind alles versuche die das das
Leben der Korrespondenten schwerer zu
machen aber die Frage ja es ist
natürlich unangenehm einfach da ewig
dann am Flughafen zu stehen und dann
eben noch eine extra Befragung zu
bekommen und natürlich die verkürzten
Visa Fristen die jetzt von einem Jahr
auf drei Monate herabgesetzt sind sein
unglaublicher Aufwand man ist halt eben
viel mehr mit Bürokratie als mit Dingen
mit großen Recherchen die man sich
wünschte beschäftigt und muss sich
einfach den die Zeit für die Recherchen
freikämpfen aber auf der anderen Seite
denke ich ist es auch unser Job dass wir
uns davon nicht einschüchtern und davon
nicht behindern lassen dann am Ende in
der Arbeit so gut wir können und deshalb
sage ich auch was ich was ich denke und
was ich meine und was an möglichen
Folgen da steht wir haben Fälle gehabt
die Deutsche Welle ist wie wir wissen
ausgewiesen worden die mussten dann in
kürzester Zeit packen wurden zum
ausländischen Agenten erklärt das kann
passieren der BBC ist das auch passiert
aber solange es nicht passiert berichten
schreiben reden wir weiter
zum Schluss die Frage an sie hat human
wir haben über viele dunkle und
bedrohliche Dinge jetzt gesprochen was
lieben sie an Russland
ich liebe es an Russland mit meinen
Freunden zu sitzen jetzt wieder mehr in
den Küchen wie früher in der Sowjetunion
und richtig das Herz auszuschütten und
auf Russisch einfach lange in den in den
Abend rein zu reden und sich dabei
einfach lachend weinend in den Armen zu
liegen es leben tolle Menschen in
Russland und deshalb liebe ich auf
dieses Land
Michael Thumann herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch danke schön vielen Dank für die
Einladung
[Musik]